hi everyone welcome to PI data art April
gathering I'm Patricia Schuster I'm a
postdoc at the University of Michigan
one of the co-organizers together with
Sean wah and Ben's I learned her over
there I want to start by thanking our
sponsors we have Numb focus who sponsors
the meetup group itself TD Ameritrade
provides the space for us to gather and
- has purchased our dinner so if you
know people from these organizations and
you see them please say thank you for
sponsoring our group a few quick
announcements we have an emergency exit
here in case we need to use it and is
there one back there as well okay no
elevators feedback we're always looking
for feedback on the group on the quality
of your experience there's a number of
different ways you can contact us you
can tell us directly or you can contact
us on Twitter or gmail with these names
here and we're in a borrowed space so
please clean up after yourself no one's
clear point ok QA we all have time for
Q&A at the end so unless your questions
are quick just hold your questions till
the end and please
phrase your question in the form of the
question keep the conversation moving
try to keep your questions short under
30 seconds and avoid long statements or
monologue so you can always approach the
speaker or another participant afterward
if you want have a longer conversation
now I'll read our code of conduct hi
data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free meeting experience for
everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression
disability physical appearance body size
race or religion
we do not tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meetup events be kind to
others do not insult or put-down other
attendees behave professionally remember
that harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pie data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meetup
at this whole discretion of the meetup
organizers thank you for helping make
this a welcoming
the event for all so of course we have a
very diverse audience in terms of like
background so additionally if someone
doesn't understand a concept you can
explain it to them and there's just no
assumption that that people should know
everything that's presented to them so
we're all open with our ideas here so
we're going to do a quick icebreaker you
can meet two people around you so
today's question since we have a speaker
coming from Philly what is your favorite
city in the u.s. that you visited and
why so I would just introduce yourself
to the people near you
I like Boulder a lot very pleasant
please yeah not really a city
[Laughter]
Wow yeah so I just learned a good all
the way across the city to go to the
games
[Music]
people generally kinda tattoo of like
the Steelers in the face or something to
hang one's really taken to it that like
you really all right can I hear a few
favorite cities just a few quick hands
or just call it out la New York Santa Fe
where's that okay Ann Arbor okay yes and
our speakers favorite city is Boulder
Colorado so this month in data science
so Shawn told me about this interesting
blog post that comes from Capital One
and they are doing hyper parameter
optimization at scale so trying to
accomplish this for companies with large
amounts of data a lot of people are
using this data and in fact this is
relevant to our speaker in June whose
company is working on similar solutions
and our next speaker for May is Caitlin
who Don who is working on building data
science and that will be May 13th Monday
so usually we're doing on Wednesday
but this was a special ones on Monday
okay also there's a conference coming up
in Ann Arbor called
not another big data conference on May
10th and 11th Sean is speaking so maybe
you consider attending and supporting
him okay now I'd like to take a minute
to do some community announcements so
for instance if you have an event that
you're planning that you want to share
with everyone or if you're looking for
to hire someone or you're looking for a
job
feel free to stand up and announce that
you're looking for a job yes King
excellent okay so if you're interested
in talking to keen about this please
you know connect with him after the
presentation any other thanks Logan yeah
so my name is Logan I work on our data
science engineering team here at TD
Ameritrade we are hiring for an AI and
data science developer charlie here in
the front row is also on our team I'm we
just posted the position today and
hopefully beat up by tomorrow
at careers TD Ameritrade Tom but I'm
gonna leave these with Charlie so if
you're interested you can see him
afterwards he's easy to find these like
six seven or so this is more of a junior
to mid-level so definitely Python if you
know a job as well it'd also be
preferable but yes yes
excellent any any others okay well thank
you for sharing those so now I'd like to
introduce our speaker Julia signal is a
software developer at anaconda Inc we're
currently working on developing best
practices for Python using earth
scientists earth scientists who use
Python I messed up the tone of it she
works on visualization tools within the
PI vis ecosystem and data injection and
analysis tools in the broader PI data
world she lives in Philadelphia and
previously did hydrology research at
Princeton studying lightning and rain
patterns water movement through the
landscape and stream flow very cool so
let's welcome our speaker Julia I have
posted all my material to this github
repo you should be able to find it it's
just my name and then PI data in our
birth 2019 so if you want to check that
out
everything I'm gonna be showing here it
will also be there so I'm gonna be
running through mostly all this is gonna
be live demo so hopefully it works and
if you can't see every bit of it feel
free to go to the repo check it out I'm
gonna be talking about using PI data and
private to analyze earth science data so
our science data has this unique or not
unique but this challenge of having
multi-dimensional data sets we always
have that lawn and we often have time
and then we have whatever we actually
care about so these are all stored in
idiosyncratic file formats there's
netcdf files there's azar there's all
sorts of different file formats and so
there's this so what I'm going to be
talking about is the workflow for earth
scientists using PI data and PI this PI
data and and privates are kind of these
opinionated sets of tools that we use
that we recommend using and so that
starts with a data ingestion so in this
case I'm gonna be talking about using
intake to get from the file format
itself into a data set that you can work
with in Python and then you can work on
that data set
using x-ray which uses desk behind the
scenes to do parallel computing and then
you can iterate doing analysis using
desk and x-ray to analyze your data once
you have your data set up in a way
that's ready for visualization you can
then use HB plot which uses data shader
and bouquet to generate figures and then
you can go to more of an interactive
dashboard using panel so this is just
the overview of what I'm going to be
talking about but all these tools you
can find them on private org or also
they're just standard PI data tools so
I'm going to be talking about a a
specific case study which is this heat
and street trees case study so this is
Philadelphia zoomed in in this case but
we're going to be making this dashboard
that allows you to to set the threshold
for the surface temperature that you're
looking at and to look at where the
trees are placed and explore how the
surface temperature interacts with the
or the relationship between the surface
temperature and the density of street
trees so this work was originally done
by Ken Steve at who's at the master who
founded the master of urban spatial
analytics at Penn he did it all in GIS
I saw a talk of his and then I decided
to recreate it using our tools and then
I extended it to have interactivity so
that's the basis of this you can read
about his work at this blog but yeah all
of it was done in Azeri tools so I just
thought it'd be interesting to see how
much of that we could recreate in open
source tools so I binder eyes this so
you should be able to just click on this
thing get to binder and run that
interactively without doing any
downloads I don't know if people have
heard of binder before but it's just an
open source or it's an open place where
you can host different environments and
content it might take a while to load
because
there's a lot of dependencies you can
also run it locally all right so let's
get into it so I haven't run any of this
I just restarted it so it should just go
so first we're gonna do a bunch of
imports this notebook is going to be
requiring a special package that's put
out by West stereo which is a top for
top of atmosphere calculations so we're
gonna be using Landsat data to calculate
the surface temperature of the earth and
then we'll be looking at that in more
detail so here's some info about Landsat
data it's basically a satellite that
takes images at a bunch of different
frequencies and these are the
descriptions of the different
frequencies and you can use these
different bands to calculate different
products so we're going to be using the
red the near-infrared and then the
thermal infrared layers so those are the
ones were interested in today but all
the bands can be used for different
things all those data are available on
Google Cloud storage and on s3 so I've
written an intake catalog intake is a
package that we have been working on
really active we had anaconda it's fully
open source but it's for ingestion so
it's a way of specifying in a gamal
specification exactly how your data are
meant to be loaded into Python so this
is the thing that's been thought about
for a long time but the idea is that
instead of having the top section of
every piece of code that you write be a
bunch of read CSV read blah blah blah
this is the separation you can just
extract that into a gamma file and then
you never have to think about it again
that's the goal and you can also
distribute that alongside your data and
then no one has to think about it so
I've written that for the Google the
Google Cloud Storage Landsat bands and
that's described here
so we're only looking at specific bands
I won't go into this in too much detail
but if people are interested we can talk
about it more later but basically we
choose the path in the row and the
product ID those things you have to
figure out but then you will be able to
go and get that exact band so that
defines the area that's generally above
Philadelphia I went and like looked for
what those numbers were in this case but
that but you should be able to go and
take a different path and band if you're
interested in a different area I'm gonna
open a - client just so we have it for
later in case we want to look at it this
will show us what desk is up - in the
background but we won't bother with it
right now
so now we're going to load the data from
that intake catalog and store it in a
desk or in a desk x-ray object so this
is using x-ray which is kind of
analogous to pandas but for n
dimensional data it's a really great
library if you want to check it out it's
not developed by anaconda and it behind
the scenes it's using gas so you can see
here it says desk array so that means
that our data is not actually loaded in
yet we've just read the metadata so that
you that didn't take very much time at
all right so and I don't have the data
cached locally so the data is not there
yet but we do know all this information
about it and one thing we know about it
is the coordinate reference system since
this is geographic data it's projected
and we need to know more about what that
projection is so we'll grab that off
we'll store it as a car - PI object and
then we're going to try and figure out
what area is over Philadelphia so that
we only look at the area that we're
interested in because right now our
dataset is like seven thousand by seven
thousand by four so so it's a fair
amount of data we don't want to have to
be dealing with all that if we don't
have to so I'm going to get this
neighborhood data from open data Philly
this is a geo JSON [ __ ] this is a geo
JSON file so we read it in using geo
pandas and now we have these different
geometries that we can use to get the
area of Philadelphia so I'm going to get
the bounds of those geometries
so this is yeah that's just the bounds
of different geometries and then we can
get the lower corner the upper right
corner and we can pull out the lat lawn
of the area that we're interested in
we'll use that to we'll convert that
into the coordinate reference system
that we're interested in and then we'll
use that to subset our data into the
area that we actually care about so now
we have our subset we're going to
persist it so that we have it in memory
so that everything will be faster from
now on so we have this now you'll see
that our data sets a lot smaller it's a
thousand by a thousand so that'll take
be a lot quicker to do all the rest of
our computations so now we can create
another we have that sorted we have our
area that we're interested in we can
take a look at it make sure that it
looks right so to do that just do a
quick this is going to use a lot of
different tools really quick but
basically if you're comfortable using
the pandas dot plot API does anyone use
that use planners up plot okay some
people this is a similar API it's based
on them it uses a bunch of arguments so
it's kind of data first approach so you
use your data and then you call that HV
plot which is analogous to dot plot and
then you set some different variables on
some different arguments on that so in
this case we're going to use data shader
to condense all our data aggregate it to
the pixel and then we'll plot that
rather than plotting all of our data all
at once
and then we're going to set the
coordinates reference system so that
it's actually geo-referenced we're going
to set the color map and the height and
the width and then we're going to make a
neighborhood pot using the geo JSON that
we've voted and we're going to make that
geo and then we're going to also color
it by this our attribute called map name
so let's make that this will take a
minute because it's grabbing all that
data and rendering it so this is um
that's
that's a shape of philly people are
interested in that but you see that we
have all this this is the neighborhood's
that we've rendered and then underneath
it that's bad for bad cover text but we
have all the different this is the
Landsat imagery that I've just rendered
in gray here because the color is not
very meaningful for just one band so you
can zoom in as you zoom in it gets more
you've got messed up there but as you
zoom in it gets more more resolute okay
so we've got the right area now we can
calculate then the NDVI the vegetative
index so this is very easy to calculate
we just take the near-infrared and the
infrared band the near-infrared and the
red bands and do this calculation and we
can get the NDVI this is just the first
step for calculating surface temperature
so we just need that we can plot it just
to make sure that it looks normal so
you'll see that the water has really
high NDVI and then more urban areas have
lower and DVI and then we'll use the
thermal infrared bands to calculate land
surface temperature so I'm using these
these these functions that come in from
this special library that was made for
doing these kind of calculations that's
one of the nice things about using these
open source tools is that you can depend
on other people to write some of the
stuff and then I've written a little
land surface temp calculation these are
all very a couple Bowl things it just
pulls in some constants uses NDVI and
and you're good to go
so then this is just a function a little
helper function to get the land surface
temperature from a band and then we need
to know the metadata that goes along
with the Landsat imagery so that'll come
in from that will come in from MATLAB
text file so it has a kind of ugly read
function so
this is another thing that I should
probably dump into an intake spec and
then we can read that in and then we'll
get the land surface temperature from
each of these bands I didn't quite set
up my dots graph the idea way so it's
doing more work than it needs to which
it's warning me about but that it did
finish so now we have the land surface
temperature for each of these bands and
we can plot that so you see in that when
you weigh how we have land surface
temperature this is in Fahrenheit and we
have these two different bands that are
giving us different values for it and we
can zoom in and they zoom together and
we can see well we've got got this
really hot area that we're probably
going to look at a lot more so because I
have two different values I'll just take
the mean of those x-ray makes it really
easy to do calculations like this across
different levels of your data so since
our data set has these two bands we can
just take the mean across band and we'll
get that then we can plot that and check
out the the land surface temperature so
now we've plotted it we can still see
that really hot patch that we were
looking at before and I plotted it over
a tiling service so you can see the
imagery below that's from ESRI ESRI
imagery tiling service that they provide
so we're starting to get somewhere so
the next spot the next thing to do is to
try and it is kind of hard to see this
kind of color map over the imagery so
the next thing I want to do is do some
threshold encoder map that's just fred's
you don't have to worry about this too
much but it's just a whisk that I've
grabbed a piece of and then we're going
to take the only the area that's above
90 degrees and we're going to plot that
and so now we can see just those areas
that are really really hot and we can
look at those in more detail and that
kind of allows us to see more what's
going on I think so we can see that
there's these really hot patches over
this black roof for instance which is to
be expected so the next thing that we're
going to be looking at is adding in
another layer of data adding in the
street tree data and we're going to be
looking at adding more interactivity to
these plots so I'm going to save off
that mean temperature data into a
different data set so we can use it
going forward
we won't have to redo all our work so
I'm saving that into a into a into a
czar okay next notebook so now we're
going to load in the the tree data so it
all comes from this it's again geo JSON
and takes a while to download because
it's a hundred thousand lines of geo
JSON which is not a very efficient data
storage format but it's well understood
and we're going to use a tree pot again
to render that data we're only going to
render the first 10,000 because it's a
little slow and then we'll we'll make it
faster and we'll render it all it so in
this case I guess yeah so this data you
can see if you zoom in it takes a while
to rerender so it should when a user a
minute should be render so that it
aggregates to just a smaller size so you
can see individual trees so that took a
while so I wanted to make it faster so
we can look at the data we can see that
each of these points each of these rows
is just a point and it doesn't really
have any attributes of interest other
than the geometry so this is just a lot
lawn and we can extract that into a
regular pandas dataframe so we'll do
that and then we can see that if we put
now we're parting all the points not
just the first 10,000
and you can see that it's a lot faster
it's a lot more responsive and you can
zoom in and out and it just is nicer so
save that off yep yep city did that
their street tree is only yeah that's a
good no they're not Park trees they're
not personal trees they're just street
trees Philly has a big program of
distributing street trees and they then
tagged them all I think they got a bunch
of interns yeah yeah
okay so we'll save that off into a more
optimized file format for columnar data
which is parque it's like UCSB but
better and then now we're going to I
can't explain that much on it but
basically it's it's for Coulomb in our
data but it's chunked so you can read
from it just the chunk that you need and
it makes it a lot faster yeah that's my
Park HBO I guess so there's kind of
these data file formats that we
recommend for different different types
of data parque is the one that we
recommend for 2d data and as our as the
one that we recommend for a dimensional
data so we're going to read in our data
sets so for the interaction we're going
to be using panel which is a new
relatively new package that we've been
developing in the PI vis ecosystem so
this is our so this is our dashboarding
solution so it's for creating these
interactive visualizations that have
widgets that have different things that
respond to different parts of the
interaction it's based on bouquet and
it's which is an interactive
visualization library that creates the
book the link between Python and
JavaScript and allows all this stuff to
work
okay so we've read in our data we're
creating our little color map with the
reds and then we're going to try so the
first way that I tried to make this
trash holding interact
was to use the panel that interact magic
so here we've used it I've used a
decorator - like widget eyes the
function so we have a function that
takes an argument which has a default
value and then we can set the range that
we expect that default value to have and
call panel dot interact and we'll get a
slider that we can use to control that
so here's our just barely fits you can
slide this threshold and not a we render
and change the change the little dark so
but yeah you can see that if you slide
this it'll rerender but one thing that's
annoying about this approach is that it
renders a whole graph doesn't maintain
your zoom doesn't maintain anything
another thing that's bad about it is
that it recomputes the data so it's not
very efficient and also it requires a
Python kernel to be running so you can't
do it statically so I was looking for a
different approach so we're going to use
color clipping instead color clipping
defines the ranges of the color bar
rather than sub setting the data to only
include the data that you need so you
keep the same plot but you just change
how you're rendering it so we're gonna
equip the colors so that anything below
our color bar is transparent or anything
above our color bar transparent and then
you'll see that looks kind of similar
now we have no interaction though so we
need to add the interaction backs in
back in and we can use JavaScript
linking directly for that so I'm going
to define a widget which is a range
slider that has a start and a start
value and an end value of the min and
Max temperature and then we'll link it
to the color mapper going high value so
there I did have to write a little bit
of JavaScript but it wasn't too bad
so that'll allow us to have this widget
that can control the temperature without
we rendering the pot these guys are over
here so you can see that it maintains
your zoom and it's also a lot faster and
more responsive so and this will work in
a static website because it doesn't
require any Python kernel to be running
because it's all just JavaScript at this
point once it's rendered so now we're
gonna add in the layer of the tree data
so let's pot that and then since it's a
dashboard thing be nice to have maybe a
tree thing a tree toggle to toggle the
tree layer on and off so we've got that
this is the same thing where you set up
a simpler j/s link which sets the value
of the toggle to equal the the visible
of the renderer so it can toggle on and
off using just JavaScript and then we'll
set up a base map layer which is that
from the tiling service and we'll use
this is this this is the last approach
is a little more convoluted I think but
it uses a hall of use to create a
dynamic map which accepts a stream from
a widget so the widget sets a value and
then this will update over here so now
that we've got all those different
components we can maybe add a couple
more so these are alpha sliders to
control the how it all looks and then we
can create a dashboard to this row and
column grid style thing to combine all
the different elements that we've
defined above
so we then can render that and we've got
our dashboard so this is a so this all
just works anything that I since I
defined this above it stays defined here
so we can change it back to our original
value you can
still have our bouquet tooltips over
here so you can zoom in and it'll
rerender the trees to be small again and
we can also turn that layer on and off
we can change the Alpha so you can see
really what's going on with that surface
temperature and we can change the Alpha
of the trees as well in case we want to
see more clear what's going on there so
the the purpose of this whole work was
to look at the relationship between the
surface temperature and roof color
there's a big campaign in Philly right
now to get people to paint their roofs
white because it makes a huge difference
so you can really see that when you add
this interactivity you can really
explore and see that
yeah like the black waves really does
make a difference it really is super hot
there and then also there was this
people were interested in knowing
whether Street trees really made a
difference in terms of the heat because
there there is a hypothesis that if
there are more Street trees that there
it would be less hot overall and
specifically right around where the
trees are and that seems to be the case
it's a little hard I think to convince
yourself that that it's all about the
trees because that like there's also
just not trees on black roofs so it's
hard to a little hard to say like which
is which is going on more but you need
to like actually do stats probably to
get that but I thought it just as a as a
little visual here's this this is a Navy
Yard and you can see this area that has
a lot of trees over here is like maybe
ha oh that's hot then this area that has
none you can also see a little cloud
cover there which is probably messing
things up so the last thing that I
wanted blow this couple things I guess
left so you can also save this off into
an HTML document and most and it'll most
of the things will just work because
they're just JavaScript
the only thing that won't work is the
swishing between the different tile
levels because that requires Python to
be running the other thing you can do is
people might have experienced I PI
widgets before which traps you in a
notebook but panel doesn't do that and
you can actually serve panel you can
just do panel serve show I made a
special notebook that just had just the
final product in it but you don't need
to do that so this is what the notebook
that I'm serving here it looks like it's
just sets up all the little widgets and
only renders the dashboard it's just
slightly faster to do it that way takes
a little bit see what my zoom is okay
should be good and then I also um I
popped this up this is a static version
that I just popped up at this link so
this is just to show that this is just
static github posted think so this is
just to show that the javascript linking
really does work even in a static
version you can play around with it you
can check it out and I just took off the
layer that wouldn't work so you'll
notice that the only thing that doesn't
really work right is that the trees
don't rerender on zoom because that
requires Python to be there but you can
talk all the rest play with it see if
this thing came up okay and this is the
one with the live kernel behind it and
you can see you can change the tiling
service some of them are less helpful
than other ones and you can zoom and the
trees will be render and yeah so that's
what I wanted to show you guys I guess
the point is that you can do all this
stuff in Python using open source tools
all these tools out there you can
attribute to them you can see what's
going on and hopefully that's
informative
there's a lot of different docs that I
pulled up but basically the things that
I was showing you our intake x-ray and
then PI vis is pretty much like the rest
where you can find out about all sorts
of different stuff and it links to
different projects that I explicitly
used that's that's my spiel okay
yes okay so the question was what's the
learning curve and are there tutorials
and how do I get started on this stuff
so I think I forgot to mention that this
stuff is all separate like these are all
different things
and you can start on any piece of them
so you can use just intake and carry on
with your life use my poly or whatever
you're doing you can use just x-ray and
not use intake so they all they create
use together they create this workflow
that I think is pretty nice but they can
also be used in isolation which is more
like a bite off whole thing there's a
ton of tutorials on private there's also
there just on this website there's a
links to yeah this tutorial probably
take you a while to get through those
there's also going to be new there's new
material that's coming out I think the
panel Doc's are really nice in
particular so there's a lot of different
places to start x-ray has a lot of stuff
that's completely isolated from the PI
va's world yeah so there's a lot of
different places but you should be able
to start with just one piece and build
up from there whichever piece is like
most applicable to your stuff could you
provide some maybe
experiencer advice on if you were to if
you're doing this maybe this is where
you want to start out of the
visualization for a data visualization
tools out of the visualization tools if
you have data I would start with HB plot
because that's that's pretty much what I
do it uses the other things behind the
scenes but it allows you to do things
that are really really powerful like
like 100,000 data points without a
problem and that's because it uses
everything else behind the scenes so
that yeah that should be fairly
straightforward learning curve use some
data structure it has so the question
was whether HB part has a similar
interface to map part Lib it has the
same API as the dot plot off a data
frame so that is matplotlib but that
might not be how you're using if you're
using boo like plot dot like if you're
importing like matte positive that pipe
plot then that's not the same interface
it's this other one that's that's data
first and then all the other arguments
yeah yep
no just HTML demo how does it subset the
data when you like zoom in the map or
select things
it it doesn't rerender the data the
tiling service is calling back to find
the tiling so that's the base map is
doing its own thing we don't not worried
about that too much but the the trees
are not rerender because they only have
it only has the data that has already
been aggregated to the level of the
original plot no but you aren't gonna
read like you're never gonna get this
rear-ending like it's just gonna get
infinitely big yeah okay so the question
is whether I have familiar with the
Landsat data I didn't originally so a
lot of the work that I do is for
government contractors who are
interested in how they can use our tools
to do the work that they've been doing
in arcgis or mat lab or something so
they they came to us with some workflows
that were Landsat and then this one I
saw at a talk it's the the math is very
straightforward so that's not really a
hurdle
yeah like some suggestions on how to
like focus it um not yeah I guess I mean
I use Landsat 8 which has the right it
has like the right amount of data for me
it has the two infrared bands the older
ones I don't think have that or they
have only one band so you can read up on
it but it's all all that all the way
inside eight data is also publicly
available on google cloud storage and s3
so it's a huge amount of data that's
available so you can also just poke
around and I should have mentioned this
but it's stored as do you optimize
Tiff's so you don't have to download it
you can you don't have to download it at
all you can just go look at it get the
metadata and then get the chunk you want
and you never fetch the whole data set
which is really cool they do start
getting mad if you hit there you're all
too many times you'll get some 503 he's
but other than that you're good
anything else yeah
you have to convert that from one a PST
to the other or you have to play with
the CRS systems in order to get it
surrender or as long as you know what
the CRS is oh sorry the question is
around how you know what the CRS is for
Landsat data and how you get that to
project properly and and work with the
rest of your layers so it's kind of sped
through that part but yeah so how it's
stored in these geo optimized Tiff's the
CRS is stored as the coordinate
reference system is stored as an
attribute so we're reading it in using R
a stereo and x-ray and intake and you'll
see where is it yeah so it's stored here
as an attribute that comes along with
the data so intake does a really good
job of maintaining those attributes and
maintaining the labels that your
coordinates have and that you're all the
rest of your data have so that's one of
the huge benefits that you get from
using x-ray as opposed to using like
straight numpy arrays or something so
then in this step here I've taken that
proj for string and I've converted it
well actually I just took this chunk of
it and I couldn't use carter pi which is
a mapping library out of the Met Office
and I've created a Carter PI CRS that I
then used throughout to convey the
projection info and apply that that's a
like yeah
Hey yeah the other question
so with that I'd like to say that as a
part of doing data science it's not only
about number crunching right we've got
to keep in mind that there's a huge
amount of communication and oftentimes
that comes in the forms of the data
visualization but also interactivity and
having did it even be dynamic I think in
time later to it right so I encourage
everybody to extend their repertoire
those are the tooling that they're using
to go and explore these these types of
visualization tools yeah so with that
let's take Julia again for a great talk